so liebe leute jetzt platzt mir wirklich
der kragen bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen scheint mit der
klimaschutz wirklich komplett unter die
räder zu kommen wir deutschen bekommen
es einfach nicht hin
nicht nur dass wir die selbstgesteckten
selbstgesteckten klimaziele nicht
erreichen
auch werden die bemühungen dazu im keim
erstickt und jetzt achtung werden sogar
kommerzielle unternehmen aktiv um die
politik zur vernunft zu bringen was ist
da los leute hat eigentlich niemand den
schuss gehört wie ist also die lage beim
klimaschutz in deutschland jetzt bei
pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen zu einem etwas
meinungsstarken video
wenn bundesverkehrsminister alexander
dobrindt das ziel verbrennungsmotoren ab
2030 das ist noch lange hin nicht mehr
zuzulassen als schwachsinn bezeichnet
dann frage ich mich wirklich wie er das
den hitze orkan und sonstigen klima
opfern in den nächsten jahrzehnten
erklären will
jetzt haben wir schon millionen tote
durch die folgen des klimawandels das
ist wirklich einfach eine bodenlose
unverschämtheit und komplettes
unvermögen aber das hatten wir hier ja
schon als das bundesverkehrsministerium
nicht in der lage war die rechtlichen
grundlagen für die hyper look planung in
deutschland zu klären ja zukunft und csu
da scheinen zwei welten aufeinander zu
prallen okay das war jetzt polemisch
aber es kommt einem so vor jetzt haben
also die grünen auf dieses enddatum 2030
verzichtet und auch auf ein konkretes
jahr für den endgültigen kohleausstieg
wie bitte leute das geht nicht jetzt
müssen sogar unternehmen also
kommerzielle gewinnorientierte
unternehmen vorangehen um die wirklich
von allen guten geistern verlassenen
politiker und politikerinnen zur ordnung
zu rufen 40 konzerne wie all die die
telekom siemens die deutsche bahn adidas
und so weiter und so fort haben mit der
stiftung zwei grad die zukünftigen
regierungsparteien aufgefordert zitat
ein konsistentes konzept vorzulegen wie
die 2020 ziele und die ziele des
klimaschutzplan 2050 erreicht werden
können
das saß wie peinlich ist das denn die
von uns gewählten volksvertreter und
vertreterin sind nicht in der lage für
uns für das wohl ihres volkes die
richtigen dinge zu tun
was ist denn hier los man fühlt sich
echt verraten und verkauft was treibt
also einen verhandlungspartner alexander
dobrindt zu und jetzt muss ich mal zur
seiner äußerung sagen diesem schwachsinn
es wäre lustig wenn es nicht so ernst
wäre deutschland wird die
selbstgesteckten klimaziele bis 2020
einfach mal nicht erreichen
die bundesregierung hat auf ganzer linie
versagt statt 40 werden die treibhausgas
emissionen lediglich um im besten fall
32 prozent gegenüber 1990 gesenkt und
von einer million elektroautos 2020 da
können wir nur träumen anfang 2017 waren
es 34 1022 peinlich und jetzt kommt die
autoindustrie noch mit ein paar
lobbyisten
eine lobbyistin also eine frau ist dabei
da muss ich mir den plural jetzt mal
sparen tatsächlich 14 männer und eine
frau
da sieht man mal direkt wo die blödheit
daheim ist wettern gegen elektroautos
das sind alles übrigens professoren und
experten fährverkehr nach eigener
auskunft und die kritik an elektroautos
ist wirklich und da wird man mir
verzeihen warum hier vom blödheit
spreche schwachsinn achtung an zweiter
stelle kritisieren sie die
feinstaubbelastung durch ihre hohe
beschleunigung wo man lieber gott lass
hirn regnen was ist das denn ja es ist
richtig ich kann mit meinem
elektro-smart an porsche versagen aber
wie oft mache ich das wohl
ich muss ehrlich sagen dass ich noch
nicht so viele kavalier starts von
elektroautos gesehen habe und haben die
lieben professoren auch berücksichtigt
dass die elektroautos fast keinen abrieb
an ihren bremsbelägen haben weil sie
statt die bremsen zu nutzen mit ihrem
elektro motor bremsen um energie zu
gewinnen
die kooperation nennt man das 100
quellen in diesem pamphlet so muss man
es mal nennen gibt es fast presseartikel
und moment eine sekunde zwei studien und
die belegen meines erachtens noch nicht
mal die hauptthesen es ist also alles
nur nicht wissenschaftlich und sie
kritisieren dass elektroautos nicht
emissionsfrei sind sprich sie
argumentieren gegen diese bezeichnung
erklären dass es keine emissionsfreie
fortbewegung geben kann also erst mal
ist das natürlich falsch fahrradfahrer
im fußgänger und so weiter können die
professoren eines besseren belehren und
das ist damit auch gar nicht gemeint es
geht ja darum dass diese fahrzeuge da wo
sie fahren keine emissionen erzeugen
also nicht andere verkehrsteilnehmer
vergiften das ist der punkt und selbst
wenn sie also mit energie die aus kohle
gas und so weiter gewonnen wird
angetrieben werden dann wird dort in
grösserem und effektiveren stil
entgiftet als vor ort im straßenverkehr
wo einfach kein gift das im boden näher
ausgestoßen wird hingehört das ist
schwachsinn herr dobrindt und bei brady
ladesäulen herr in berlin werden mit
regenerativen energien gespeist und auch
bei mir zu hause gibt es ökostrom die
vergleiche in diesem durchsichtigen
versuch der autoindustrie einfluss auf
die koalitionsverhandlungen zu nehmen
hinken hinten und vorne
ich könnte noch so weiter machen das ist
einfach hanebüchen wir brauchen jetzt
einen umschwung und
eine verlängerung des leidens wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln geht die ganze welt
über die wupper zumindest die menschheit
wird das nicht überleben und ja ganze
entwicklungsabteilungen in deutschland
müssen jetzt von verbrennungsmotoren auf
batterieentwicklung umschwenken die
produktion muss umgestellt werden und
und und ja das ist der wandel der zeit
und wie so schön heißt wer nicht mit der
zeit geht geht mit der zeit es ist so
einfach und herr dobrindt vielleicht
sind sie der erste der das begreifen
wird sagt jetzt habe ich dampf
abgelassen sagt mir eure meinung soll
ich ab und zu mal dampf ablassen und wir
diskutieren hier unter dem video
engagiert und fair schreibt sie die
kommentare wenn er kein video von dix
und verpassen wollt dann tut mir hier
ein abo aufsaugen und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt so ist es nämlich
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran